Cómo proteger su rostro y dónde golpear
a un agresor para neutralizarlo 50
miembros de la comunidad lgbtiq más
chilena escucharon los consejos de esos
tres campeones de muay thai el boxeo
tailandés participaron en este taller
gratuito de defensa personal para
aprender a reaccionar cuando son
Víctimas de agresiones por ejemplo
entonces llevarlo es difícil así como es
mejor tenemos algo con lo que recibir
ese momento
en 2022 los crímenes de odio contra las
personas lgbtiq más se duplicaron En
comparación con 2021 o incluso seis
homicidios las cifra más alta registrada
para Ignacio esta actividad también
puede servirle para su vida diaria en el
marco del aumento de La criminalidad
callejera en Chile a mí me da un poco de
miedo en la calle así como en la noche o
cosas así porque
puede pasar cualquier cosa y es súper
bueno que integren esto a personas
sobre todo porque es lo que más lo
necesitan según el último informe anual
de derechos humanos de la diversidad
sexual y de género en Chile el año
pasado se registraron más de mil casos
de discriminación en cuanto al mutaya es
el deportín nacional de Tailandia y
desde 2021 fue como de categoría
olímpica por esa razón en unos próximos
juegos podría estar presente en la
competencia